so rato what have we learned in this
lesson
well I learned that I do not want to
write databases and content providers
what did you learn in this lesson well
Jayne unit tests are awesome and
building the backend framework of our
apps is the most glorious of work it's
an absolutely vital part of creating a
robust app with a great user experience
I also learned that Dan cannot do an
English accent
fortunately you can get ready to welcome
back Catherine for less than five where
will shatter our activity into fragments
use our content providers to populate
more complex UIs and build layouts that
work as well on tablets as they do on
phones which seems like a convenient
segue into the history and evolution of
Android hardware